[Music]
hey folks welcome to the dark horse
podcast live stream
winter is leaving
we are at number 119 am i correct about
that we're at livestream 119 and as we
stream to you today on march 19th it is
the final day of winter in the northern
hemisphere the final day of winter
making tomorrow the solstice no the
equinox yes yes in which uh day and
night are
equal um
in length although of course because
uh in in physics anyway
light spreads and darkness does not
in a planet on a planet with an
atmosphere of course there is actually
more light more time with light than
with darkness on the equinox uh in the
rest of the world in the social world
darkness seems to do a very good job of
spreading uh there is there is a lot of
darkness and it does seem to be
spreading kind of almost like it's
oozing yeah now the shadows they expand
their reach in a way that um
you know sunlight being the best
disinfectant would that there were a
metaphorical truth there as well it's
not always the case it seems right well
um i mean there are other
aphorisms we could go to uh it's always
darkest before it goes pitch
black um
that's that's one i don't know if that's
helpful but uh or true
no it i think it actually
um
yes i think it is because
inherently it's like the ball has to go
to uh a speed of zero before it reverses
direction and falls back down yeah but
if pitch black is actually darker than
what it was before then it wasn't
darkest right before then
short of pitch black it is it is as dark
as it gets all right aphorisms don't you
don't get caveats with aphorisms um
you don't get caveats with aphorism is
that a rule i think so okay that should
be enough that japan aphorism wow okay
here we are we are early today
uh some of us at least one of us has not
had any coffee or anything so here we go
well i i had i had coffee it did not
help you had coffee for both of us
perhaps
um
yeah it's spring it's spraying and that
uh that that does help um with the rest
of the world would follow along uh we've
got some announcements we have uh as as
usual we'll have three sponsors at the
top of the show and then the rest of the
show is ad free
and uh then we're going to talk about um
talk about loudly talk about uh trans
athletes we might talk a little bit
about a nobel laureate uh we're gonna
bring these things together
um i i feel a theme emerging it's like
one of those situations where uh you
know back when we were teaching at
evergreen there was this phenomenon
where you had a sort of plan about what
you were going to teach but actually
things tended to gel
after you got it all on the table in a
way you didn't expect so i'm hoping for
that
i'd say okay
i'm not sure that was exactly my
experience but uh we had very different
approaches
uh didn't we so but today i am i am i'm
pleased to go with uh with your plan
excellent um
okay a couple a couple of announcements
before our ads before we dive right in
and then you know once once we're into
the mini brother share we're going to
try to keep it relatively uh relatively
quick today because we are coming to you
early because
uh we have we have some place to be
that's that's all i'll say for right now
so um there's a podcast out this week
that we did last week uh called the
evolution of medicine with host james
maskel this is we've not listened to it
but we participated in it and it was a
it was really a terrific conversation
and uh and we got his book this is the
community cure he's actually written too
but this is the community cure by james
maskel
um transforming health outcomes together
is the is the subtitle and he and uh the
people around him that the people with
whom he works
are
have been working hard for many years to
transform
how medicine is practiced and how people
experience medicine and therefore their
own health
and i am i've just begun to dip into
this book it seems great certainly the
conversation with him was terrific and
um it left i think i speak for both of
us with
a lot more hope about the future of
healthcare and medicine potentially
globally but we know the most about the
u.s situation
than i've had in a very long time
well i would put it a little a little
differently i would say
there's tremendous reason for hope in
our discussion but as always the
question is
what school of thought is going to win
out and in so many places
you know we have the materials to do
much better than we are doing
but we are in some sort of a battle with
forces that are capable of derailing
superior ideas in favor of i don't know
what i presume are lucrative ideas so
anyway i guess the point is listen to
the podcast and see if you don't hear a
more reasonable rational approach to
medicine than you typically get from
mainstream sources and then ask yourself
this question if that's true
why aren't you hearing more of this yeah
yeah good
and so we'll put the link to that uh to
the podcast in the show notes
um speaking of books our book is still
out there hunter gatherers guide the
21st century we heard actually i don't
remember it was this week or last week
that it's been adopted
um as again um as a text in a college
class this time a sociology class and
this just this this thrills me as a as a
way to introduce evolutionary thinking
um to people i think that's that's
wonderful so um consider picking it up
um at a bookstore at a library wherever
um and and taking a look if you haven't
uh the live the chat if you're with us
live is live on odyssey we're also on of
course youtube for
for the time being and uh
and some other places you can ask your
questions for the second hour
at uh www.darkhorsesubmissions.com
what oh right now on my patreon for uh
members at patrons at the 11 up level
you can ask questions for our monthly q
a which our private q a which happens
next sunday um that's always a lot of
fun and uh we
we have we have fun with that and you do
with your conversations at your at your
patreon you can think of that private q
a as dark horse dominance as opposed to
dark horse submissions it's you know
two different ways to approach the dark
horse podcast
okay
yeah okay
uh left you speechless didn't i you you
did you did uh
we've got we've got stuff we got
merchandise at
darkhorsepodcast.store.darquisepodcast.org
and um
as always weekly weekly posts um from me
at
naturalselections.substance.com but i'm
not i'm not sort of feeling like
pitching all these things right now so
let us go into
uh the three ads for the week
we actually have two
two brand new sponsors to us this week
and one one that is tried and true so i
will start with the first brand new
sponsor but we'll go to the next one and
then i will wrap it up with our with our
tried and true sponsor they are
blinkist bright move and soul
so our first sponsor this week is
blinkist a company founded on the idea
that almost none of us have the time to
read everything we'd like to read
yet we lose countless hours to
activities that bring us little joy such
as commuting or chores or staring at our
phones
blinkist encapsulates books into their
most concentrated forms and allows users
to take away valuable ideas by investing
times they might otherwise have lost
blinkist is 10 years old this year and
their theme is 22 ideas for 2022.
there are so many books that i want to
read as regular listeners and viewers
the podcast will recognize i'm i'm
reading many books at all times but uh
i'm
i'm fairly discerning and i'm also not a
particularly fast reader and so you know
the pile the teetering piles near and on
my nightstand
don't seem to shrink they instead seem
to grow even as i read them
blinkist provides a way to learn and
clear the list to some degree what books
this blink is perfect for which ones
don't i need to or want to know any more
about and which weren't an actual read
i use blankets for books i'm interested
in because i know the authors and
respect them and i'm curious to see what
else they've done daniel pink's drive
for instance which is about motivation
specifically what he calls motivation
3.0
and he talks about relying on intrinsic
rather than extrinsic motivation and in
the blinkist version of pink's drive i
found reinforcement of conclusions that
we had come to teaching college for so
many years
i also use blinkist for books i've heard
about and want to know more but i'm
unlikely to read in full such as atomic
habits by james clear the blinkist on on
that is um is clear indeed and fabulous
and i also use blinkist as a kind of
library i have on my nightstand for
instance debt by david graber um and
we've talked about graver um on the show
before but it's very long and i haven't
gotten far into it um and it's been
there a long time
uh when i look up debt on blinkist i
find other books on similar topics that
are intriguing much like browsing the
stacks of a library this process of
discovery can be some of the most
wonderful aspects of looking through
blinkist finding things you didn't know
you were looking for didn't know existed
and quickly learning something new
blinkist has abundant and excellent
content to help you become more
empowered inspired and motivated in 2022
and presumably beyond right now blinkist
has a special offer just for our
audience go to blinkist.com darkhorse to
start your free 7-day trial and get 25
off of blinkist premium membership
that's blinkist
b-l-i-n-k-i-s-t
blinkist dot com slash darkhorse for 25
off and a seven day free trial once
again that's blinkist.com
darkhorse all right now our second uh
sponsor is also new and it requires a
little bit of explanation our second
sponsor is brightmove and
as you all know we have taken a pledge
not to recommend things that we are not
in a position to recommend based on
what we know now in this case this is
not a service that we have used so i
have to explain to you how it is that we
are confident in recommending it
we're confident recommending it because
the company what is the service the
service uh is a recruiting tool i'll get
to the details of that shortly applicant
tracking system right an applicant
tracking system and it was uh
the company was co-founded by david webb
who's the current ceo
now
uh david
became known to me as he joined forces
for unity 2020 where he did a lot of
excellent work so not only is david
mission aligned with us here at
darkhorse
but he
was a prime mover on the ranked choice
voting system that we use to select the
unity candidates so we know he's highly
technically competent and we know he's
an excellent guy
who gets stuff done uh
beautifully so that is the basis on
which we are recommending
this service
so right move is a modern recruiting
software other than otherwise known as
applicant tracking system or ats
listeners who work in staffing companies
rpo companies and hr departments know
exactly what an ato s an ats is and if
you are not already using brightmove you
are missing out on the opportunity to
make more placements and hires
there are a lot of ats vendors to choose
from but here are just a few
differentiators that make it worth your
time
to go to brightmove
and get a personalized demo
there are new software features released
every three weeks all new features are
requested by brightmove users
who are all boots on the ground
recruiters and hiring executives
it is a hundred percent us-based
technical support that's unusual
winner of multiple customer service
awards every year recruiting analytics
show you uh exactly where your top
candidates are coming from
drag drag and drop candidate
cards through your hiring workflow
uh or kanban style dashboard all right i
assume that those of you who do this for
a living know what those things mean
better than i do but nonetheless i
highly recommend that you check out
david webb's company brightmove um and
you can visit them at brightmove.com
darkhorse if you do you will become a
customer you will receive
one month of free service depending on
your company's size and software package
that is a savings of between a thousand
and three thousand dollars visit
brightmove.com
darkhorse that's b-r-i-g-h-t-m-o-v-e
dot com slash dark horse let me just say
that you
you visit that and you schedule a
demonstration that doesn't guarantee
that you become a customer
right i'm sorry i flubbed that nope
we're good
we are good um our final sponsor today
will be familiar to those of you who've
been following along um it's seoul
seoul is a sustainable orthopedic
footwear company it's one of two
footwear sponsors that we have and we
love them both they're quite different
from one another
both have an evolutionary approach to
creating shoes that help feet get and
stay healthy and people become more
mobile
you barefoot or others specifically aims
to give you the sense of being barefoot
in your shoes soul with both their shoes
and their foot beds brings stretcher
back with intention
soul aims with its footwear to return
our feet to health and they do so and
their [ __ ] and the shoes that they make
are beautiful
souls create a foot bed that is
affordable customizable and improves
people's everyday foot comfort
furthermore they've created their own
recycling program re-cork to collect and
upcycle wine corks to make its products
millions of customers rave about this
product and two-thirds of seoul
customers have two or more pairs of
footbeds
so just be clear a lot of people have
orthotics for instance that they spend a
lot of money on and they put into shoes
in order to make shoes that may not be
perfectly designed for their feet
perfectly designed so footbeds
are far less expensive and far better
for you as i understand it and has been
my experience and you can put them in
almost any pair of shoes
our two boys are wearing the shoes much
of the time now they take some getting
used to the structure under the arch is
unusual but once you get used to them
they provide great support for feet and
again they look great
so shoes look terrific but you're just
if you're just looking for the footbeds
as i've said
um
try them seriously try them they make a
flip-flop also that isn't a flip-flop if
you're a fan of a shoe you can quickly
slip on to step outside or if it's wet
or dirty but don't want the downsides of
a flip-flop slippery having to grip your
toes to stay in it which isn't good for
your feet then this is the shoe for you
soul brings an amazing offer for first
time customers of 50 off through your
soul dot com slash darkhorse you can try
seoul that's s-o-l-e for yourself they
are so confident that you will love them
that they also offer 90-day back
guarantee it's very hard to go wrong
this offer is applicable to all items on
the sole
sole store again that's s-o-l-e be it
foot beds or footwear
that is our ads for the day
thanks we thank our sponsors very much
yes we do okay you want to leave us off
uh
we talked about various topics which
topic are we leading off with
you said you were gonna
bring it all together no that's at the
end that comes at the end of bringing it
all together
all right would you like me to start off
yes all right
um i wanted to start then with a an
exploration of a
a hidden principle maybe it's two hidden
principles in the universe the first one
i was prone uh to revisit by a tweet
from
our friend mark andreessen zach could
you put up mark andreessen's
tweet
so
since zach is
fiddling around here
um mark
uh
who of course was a we cannot read that
from here zack
um all right so mark
who was
prime mover behind
netscape mozilla
tweets overheard in silicon valley new
rule it's okay to think critically about
the previous thing
right now this is a phenomenon that i
think we have all begun to recognize
especially those of us who have been
out at the fringes of heterodoxy
in recent times which is that there is
some sort of a process by which
we are
penalized for discussing certain things
and then certain changes are made and we
are suddenly allowed to talk about
certain things so people will remember
for example the moment at which jon
stewart went on stephen colbert's
program and famously said something
hilarious about the fact that uh science
has been uh wonderful in helping us
address the pandemic which was caused by
science um suddenly it was possible to
talk about the lab leak theory in the
aftermath of that whereas before it had
been nearly impossible to do so
hypothesis
well that's the question no you're
you're right you heather has corrected
me here she has whispered uh hypothesis
and of course this has been something
i've been very careful about now the
question is
is it still a hypothesis or has it
become a theory now i do think i made
the error you suggested because no but
this is some place you're going i'm
talking about a period uh in which it
was um
still contentious and so therefore
possibly um
uh i should have said a hypothesis here
but nonetheless yes and there's many
people who would argue it's uh not only
still contentious but actually um almost
certainly false
today right and in fact this has this
has had a very interesting trajectory so
i first i want to introduce what i think
the principle the extension of mark
andreessen's point so mark is saying
that he overheard in silicon valley that
it is permissible to think critically
about the previous thing presumably his
point is something like you're not
allowed to think critically about
ukraine at the moment but you can now go
about thinking critically on covid now
that people have moved on to ukraine
my point would be
yes this is true to an extent
however there is a subsidiary principle
that people should be uh watching out
for and the subsidiary principle
is
that you can think critically about the
previous thing
but the vindication of those who thought
critically about it in real time is not
permitted right and so
we will not see the resurrection of the
reputations of people who were
stigmatized during
the initial phase
because and there's a very good reason
for this and i'm not saying it's a valid
reason but i'm saying that there's an uh
an easily understood reason and the
reason is something like
just be this this is a point about which
uh we
are often
people are often confused when you say
when you say in this case there's a good
reason
people assume what you mean is there's a
reason i like yeah or when you say
there's a good hypothesis people assume
you mean that's a hypothesis i hope is
true
and you know part of part of the problem
is language and that the language is a
little unclear but um you know what you
mean and you were very clear here but
it's a more general principle is
there is a reason that is understandable
that we can track back and see why it
might be true there is a hypothesis that
is plausible for these reasons and that
is quite separate from whether i think
it to be true but even more so quite
separate from whether i would like it or
not like it to be true and so in this
case you are about to um discuss
an idea that you know we wish were not
true
but appears to be and here's why right
so you know if you were to describe this
principle to sit down in a park bench
and try to describe this you'd want to
be careful to say uh i hope this will be
taken in a non-normative context that
way it would clarify this to you it does
sound like park bench conversation
conversation well depending upon if
you're talking to the pigeons i was
very good i was just headed to the
pigeons sure
all right so here here's the uh the
point
um
let's talk for a moment about
meritocracy and again this needs a
little bit of a caveat too um
meritocracy is a marvelous thing and to
the extent that it functions it is a
tremendous uh engine of insight and
innovation
we do not have a perfect meritocracy
anywhere so far as i'm aware so when one
invokes maritime possible
it is certainly impossible
you might be able to rig you know it
might be that uh
an infinitely iterated series of chess
games is a perfect meritocracy for
success in chess but other than a
trivial example
uh like that uh it's very difficult to
have a perfect anything and meritocracy
every variable has to be well-bounded
right and so the thing is the more
interesting the thing you're trying to
do is you're trying to accomplish the
more novel it is the noisier your
meritocracy will be even when your
meritocracy is well structured right
there will be lots of luck and things
that
impinge
but here's the point
corruption of all kinds
disrupts the search for merit right that
is what corruption effectively is is the
breaking of a system that claims to be
the pursuit of merit in favor of other
objectives like enriching some
particular
constituency or something like that
when something becomes corrupt
the thing people do not necessarily
intuit is that it becomes
often very powerful in protecting itself
but also very easy to beat
right if you have a corrupt department
that is supposed to be innovating things
then it will do a poor job because it's
really you know
feathering somebody's nest or advancing
somebody's political interests and those
things come at a cost to doing what it
is supposed to be doing this is true for
fields as well academic fields as they
become corrupt become surprisingly easy
to beat right
now
it is not surprisingly easy to beat them
and get credit for it right but if the
point is you want to you know if
predictive power is the purpose of
uh
the advancement of science
it is possible to generate more
predictive power than a corrupt field
the more corrupt the field it is the
easier it is to beat it in this regard
you can out-think it yep and so what you
get is a dynamic as corruption takes
over something
you have to find a reason to dismiss
people who are finding the thing that is
corrupt easy to beat right so you
dismiss them on the basis that they are
kooks and only a fool cannot see through
them that's a typical one
uh you know
or that they are
corrupt in their own right that the
corruption is really on the part of the
people basically the point is you
demonize the fringe
right
now the problem is for anybody who's
tracking actual predictive power the
fringe will surprisingly keep being the
place where the reality is spotted first
and uh carefully argued and the
mainstream the corrupt thing will keep
being embarrassed by those on the fringe
right so you
but the fringe will also be the home of
spectacularly wrong takes right most
which are easily pointed to as evidence
that therefore so must be all of what is
not mainstream
right and so you will get all kinds of
shell games like um okay
so and so on the fringe was right about
x
but for the wrong reasons right you'll
get little excuses like this and the
point is okay that can be true on any
one thing but it doesn't generate a
track record if you are repeatedly right
and you're not repeatedly right by
virtue of predicting everything and then
claiming those places where you were
right which is one
trivial way you could
technically uh accomplish something but
if you are in general more right than
wrong and significantly more right than
a field that has become corrupt and
therefore isn't all that interested in
being right or all that capable of
getting there
then you are a threat because over time
the question will be well okay if the
fringe is inherently uh
kooks then why is it telling me things
that turn out to be true again and again
and again
so
the fringe must never be vindicated even
if the mainstream is forced to accept
some
new
principle
now i would argue that this is happening
in multiple different domains there were
three major covet domains as
we encountered them one coveted domain
had to do with the origin of covet
itself
the other two had to do with the utility
of early treatment drugs like ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine
and the third had to do with the safety
and effectiveness of vaccines right now
in all three of these we could talk
about what it is that the fringe spotted
that you know the fringe had been
actively driven to the fringe that
actually there were things that the
mainstream should have been talking
about that it wasn't interested in
talking about
one thing that is true is that the
fringe gets defined by taking a position
that runs counter to whatever prevailing
forces are running the establishment so
there were a lot of scientists
researchers health professionals who
two years ago two and a half years ago
five years ago
thought that and appeared to be
completely within the mainstream in
terms of you know doing good work doing
honest work having integrity uh pursuing
evidence as it you know pursuing
evidence as it showed up and figuring
out what it meant and if a what then
you know what b if given a
and um we're pushed into we're vilified
we're named as people on the outside
because they arrived at conclusions that
didn't fit it's not that they were they
were or many people were not already on
the outside nor were these people who
were looking to be
fringe to be contrarian to be
outside of you know the the civilized
discourse of cocktail parties there are
certainly people like that um but this
is not the driving thing the driving the
driving thing is
what's true what are we doing oh my god
there's this there's this evolving
situation quite literally on many levels
what is true of it and therefore what
can we do to better ourselves um in the
face of you know coven two years ago and
to prepare for such a thing in the
future what is the likelihood of such a
thing and what is this thing what is the
nature of the thing right and in fact um
one of the things that tells you that
kovid is an incredibly screwed up i
would argue upside down landscape
is the high quality of the people who
are supposedly french
right so you've got you know tess lori
uh
uh attest laurie and john campbell on
ivermectin test laurie literally being a
a highly decorated who scientist you've
got um pierre corey you know who has you
know literally written a textbook on
pulmonology and is a highly decorated
icu doc
right you've got one of the world's most
published cardiologists
uh peter mccullough
you have um
you know
literally one of the uh
arguably the primary architect of the
mrna technology that went into vaccines
raising alarm about these mrna vaccines
you really couldn't ask for more highly
qualified people right but nonetheless
they are portrayed as if they are fringe
um
in fact we will get we will get back to
sam here a little bit later but sam
actually wondered about sam
harris
uh wondered aloud in in uh one of his
podcasts on the subject whether the
explanation for these people was that
they were simply part of the small
percentage of the society that's
schizophrenic well and this actually um
because because we have so much to talk
about let me just slip in here something
that i thought we might spend more time
on but
um
luke montagne
died in february uh he was a nobel
laureate he received the nobel in
2008 i want to say um
uh it was a co-recipient
uh and
he and she shared it with someone else
and i'm not just not remaining in the
specifics
but
he shared it uh with gosh i've forgotten
her name uh for the discovery of of hiv
uh and
uh
there have certainly been people who
received the
nobel
who later on
people came to think i'm not so sure
about that
the fact that luke montagne
came to
question some of
what he had understood to be true later
on
and what indeed whether or not
hiv was
uh the sole
cause of aids which is certainly not a
mainstream position and it's not
accepted within the establishment but he
was pursuing evidence he didn't say you
have to listen to me this is the only
way to proceed he said i'm i am
wondering about this and in kovid
he he came out early
by in actually talking about lab leak he
said i i cannot i cannot comprehend
given what i've seen of this virus and a
lifetime of research on viruses and
indeed as a nobel laureate that this
particular virus could have a zoonotic
origin i uh and so he
uh
he certainly was well outside the
mainstream and he has other other
positions that are well outside the
mainstream um on kovid
but at the point that he died
the obituaries were a slow incoming
and
either so benul as to be clearly
disrespectful in that regard or
um or actually disrespectful so let me
let me just say this i'm going to point
to this
i chose i said to usd earlier i chose
the wrong way to
switch to brave because nothing is quite
simple anymore
let me see if i can find it here we go
okay
um
here's a
an obit in science and one of the two
premier science journals
in the world
published just two days ago even though
he died in early february so that that
in itself is quite something
it's quite a short obituary it has um
really nothing about his controversial
positions
and it ends
with this
line
as bjorn wenstrum i don't know i don't
remember who that is remarked at the
2008 nobel ceremony montagnier was in
the right place
at the right time
that is so nasty it's so nasty and this
is how
when someone has
gotten so many accolades that it's
really hard to make them into the fringe
this this is fringe making yeah that's
that's what that is so that's it's hard
coding the analysis that luke montagne
is fringe that his success which nobody
disputes
is the result of luck right right
and he was surrounded by good people
right he got lucky and let me tell you
something scientifically speaking right
we all of us who actually get how
science works understands that it's a
self-correcting process and so this idea
that science has arrived somewhere and
we are all to follow it as [ __ ] from
the get-go
but the basic point is look
when somebody with a nobel prize a
relevant nobel prize takes up a
heterodox position especially one with a
high social cost
right you don't necessarily know that
that person is right but you do know
that you would need to know a lot
in order to dismiss them right so
let's just say okay you've got luke
montagne one of his positions
you know
the thing for which he got the prize the
discovery of hiv right his later change
of position involved his
uh
emerging belief that hiv the virus that
he discovered which nobody disagrees
exists
is a co-traveler with aids and not
causal so his new belief
down regulates downgrades the importance
of the discovery for which he got to
know his own contribution right so in a
court we would call that like statement
against interest right you're more
likely to believe this because it's not
something you would be expected to say
because it's good for you to say it
right right so okay that's interesting
does the fact that a
somebody who you know is capable enough
to get a nobel prize would reach this uh
paradoxical conclusion about the very
thing for which they got the prize
that's interesting
even more interesting when you get to
the fact that uh he wasn't the only
nobel laureate to reach that conclusion
right right carrie mullis who also
recently died and also was on the other
side he he died at the very beginning
maybe even just before before covid
but he had already ended up on the wrong
side of anthony fauci right um he
was alarmed by anthony fauci and he was
also alarmed by the uh
use of his invention
for
uh for testing for things like viruses
because he knew pcr to be so sensitive
that the cycle threshold issue made it
possible to abuse it very easily it was
not an appropriate diagnostic tool he
won the nobel for the
i guess we would say invention in case
of polymerase chain reaction as opposed
to the discovery um in the case of
montagne's prize of hiv and actually
there's a connection this is a
connection that will come back uh
in a few minutes if i can remember it um
but the connection is
like many of our best tricks in medicine
pcr is
yes it's an invention and a brilliant
one but it is borrowed almost entirely
from nature right right well that's why
i sort of paused and like it's it's an
invention um but but it uses it it's
inspired by and uses many of the tricks
that nature has used let's put it this
way its primary tools are enzymes that
we could not have written yeah right
yeah not even close we just borrowed
them from nature and they do what they
do and you know they can be modified but
uh but we just don't know enough to do
it
okay so
we've got this process of
fringe making right that has nothing to
do it's you know actually you know what
it is it's an exact parallel to that
thing we just described right this is
the manufacture of an artificial fringe
like in the center of something right
it's like you've got a carpet and you
decide to put a fringe somewhere in the
middle of it in order that people don't
pay attention to the stain or whatever
right
because
these people aren't french yeah right
now again you don't know whether luke
montagne
knows something
far beyond what you understand at the
point he says no no hiv is not causing
aids you don't know whether he's goofed
right or he's got some deep insight but
what you do know is that you can't
casually dismiss it
especially in light of the fact that
he's going after his on the nobel he's
out of kook territory
he
could be a coup right the point is
a what gets you to that level in science
is something unusual so at the point he
says something really unusual and
counterintuitive especially something
that
downgrades the importance of his own
discovery right you have to listen and
then at the point that you find another
heterodox
nobel laureate right who has reached the
same conclusion
still doesn't make them right but it
does mean hey how much would you have to
know before you were in a position to
say yeah these people
they
they've lost the threat right right
you'd have to look you'd have to know a
ton but instead the point is oh well
that's a crazy everybody knows hiv
causes aids i was like well okay
everybody knows that but you're now it
you know it's rather a lot like
uh
robert malone right
you want to say robert malone doesn't
know what he's talking about with
respect to the safety of these vaccines
really then who does
right you know if anybody is likely to
have insight
it would be robert malone and if anybody
was likely to be corrupt in the
direction of thinking that they were
safer than they are you'd expect it to
be malone because that would make his
invention that much more useful well
there are a lot of these slights of hand
and they they all have some
there's some differences between them
but another one that comes to mind is
well everyone knows that vares isn't
reliable that the you know vaccine
adverse event reporting system isn't
reliable like oh well then what are we
using right
oh we don't have anything but that
like
okay if we accept the well everyone
knows that
uh initial like you can ignore the man
behind the curtain part of the argument
um there's almost always a like well
then who or what or
you know on what basis do you know that
you know they did exactly this thing to
me on the mice too i every time i tried
to raise this issue about hey you've
created an evolutionary environment in
your mouse breeding colonies that has
created mice that are lying to you and
telling you that drugs are safe right
yup i got back it's amazing how often
people were like everybody knows the
mice are broken
and it's like look first of all if
everyone knows the mice are broken and
you're using them for drug safety
testing then that's on you second of all
there's no reason they have to be broken
this way i can tell you how to fix the
evolutionary environment in those
colonies and the point is you're not
interested because you just feel like
well i'm in the know like everybody else
you know and you're on the fringe and
it's like no the fringe is in the center
of the goddamn carpet well then again i
mean that it's it's a social argument as
opposed to an argument about reality or
about or about science right like
you're telling me something i already
knew
maybe
but two things right like you were in
fact telling them
you were you were telling them something
they already knew but with so much more
precision that you could actually you
actually had a solution for it and
and
um the idea that
because they knew something in that
territory in advance
doesn't clear them of the responsibility
for therefore basing all of their
science on a bad model
well
i was telling them something that they
could plausibly dismiss as something
they knew right they didn't really know
it right the fact of the telomere
elongation a which didn't have to happen
that was the result of them not
realizing that a colony is an
evolutionary environment and not
realizing that it was going to have a
particular
uh effect but the point is yes all
models are imperfect right a mouse is
not a person there are going to be ways
in which a mouse is an imperfect model
for people we all know that
the fact that it's broken in a
particular way especially a solvable way
right you have to be a fool to dismiss
the insight into how it's broken because
if you could fix it you know if
everybody knows the mice are broken then
wouldn't it be cool to have some mice
that were less broken right you know so
anyway it's a it's an interesting i
guess the point is it's all
specific versions of a very generic
game right the powerful people are
constantly
fringing
their detractors right no matter how
central those detractors are in the case
of
you know cory teslary
uh peter mccullough robert malone
but anyway that's a process of like
forcibly
uh painting someone as a fringe when
that's not not what they are okay so
let's try to connect this up to some
some other stuff
all right so the weird thing is
and this surprised me at the time i had
numerous conversations with uh
people who had not taken a public
position but privately were suspicious
about lab leak
as
effectively we were winning the argument
on lab league right i had numerous
conversations this is a little bit of a
surprise that we're winning usually the
enemy is so powerful that even if you
win the argument hands down you don't
win the perception of the argument right
because it is so capable of wielding its
propaganda machine to to prevent
recognition you know as it's done with
the mouse telomere thing for example
right
i haven't won that argument anywhere
except analytically
um
but okay so
uh here's what's happened with lab leak
right lab leak went from a
stigmatizable fringe
to
something unignorable where jon stewart
signaled hey it's safe for normal people
to see normal things with their regular
eyes and you know call of spade a spade
or whatever
it is
um
and now it's taken this weird uh
reversal right where suddenly as the
world has moved on to thinking about
ukraine and not thinking about kovidzo
directly there have been there's an
emergence of new papers arguing that
actually the puzzle's been solved and it
is a natural origin via the wet market
right so zach would you put up the uh
forbes article i sent you so is it not
going to turn out to be those uh frozen
ferret badger or steak popsicles or is
it going to be those i was i was sort of
excited about the prospect of those
maybe entering the markets not the that
market but you know maybe these papers
are not
completely clear okay uh
so anyway if you'll so here what we have
a classic version of the middle ground
scramble that we talked about uh
maybe two months ago so the middle
ground scramble
being people who had not
nailed the issue of the lab leak
now emerging to carve out a middle
ground
um
position
and in any case here's here's a great
example in
forbes and uh anyway if you scroll down
to the end of it zach you'll see he
covers the three
papers
that have recently emerged
back up
back up
i think you might even be in the next
article
well anyway i'm not going to waste
that
okay yep stop
stop go back down a little bit see first
paper by george gao
okay so there are three papers
um that
are being pointed to as suggesting hey
finally we've solved the problem and it
turns out
that um
that it was uh it was the the web market
all along right now these papers are not
the first one is arguably substantive
but it's not
meaningful it doesn't
reach the conclusion that is
derived so this is the first time i've
seen this forbes article and i haven't
looked at the
gow at all paper but um according to
this forbes article
the gow at all paper says that no virus
was detected in the animal swabs
covering 18 species of animals in the
market and quote in other words the
virus was found at the marketplace but
not in any of the animals suggested that
infected people walking through the
market were the source of those positive
samples where did those people get the
virus this paper doesn't answer that
question like for
right i'm trying to swear but like
people
in the city
where the first cases are
publicly recognized to have been which
is practically across the street from
the laboratory
were infected
that is no kind of smoking gun with
regard to origins at the market people
were walking through a market and were
infected and there's no evidence of the
stuff anywhere else
yeah no it it's it's nothing in the
market but then okay so that's the
george gau paper and so what about these
other two papers did they do it could
you scroll down just a little bit
okay so these other two papers
um interestingly
do not nail down
uh
what is claimed here either and in fact
interestingly
who would you expect to be a co-author
on both of these can't be peter dasic
because that would be spotted too easily
this can be what christian anderson
christian anderson right so christian
andersen all right i hear you asking
what is a christian anderson um
christian anderson is the guy who was
caught red-handed
in fouchy's
uh email exchanges what it's not the
fair pages it's the raccoon dogs raccoon
dogs right
well the thing is um
i don't know if you've ever been to the
wuhan seafood market but you get the
ferret badger popsicles and the raccoon
dog steaks from the same vending machine
so
yeah that'll do it um
all right so zach could you put up uh
the fouchy email response to christian
anderson
okay perfect so here
uh
is so this is an email from fouchy to
anderson just saying thanks christian
talk soon on the call but it uh has the
email to which he is responding this is
christian anderson's email to anthony
fauci 25 months ago who he called tony
six months ago
and the key thing is vera is at the end
of the letter here where he says
i should mention that after discussions
earlier today eddie bob mike and myself
all find the genome of sarsko v2
inconsistent with expectations from
evolutionary theory okay that is
christian anderson in a private email
telling anthony fauci uh this looks like
it came from a lab okay now put up the
proximal origins paper
i believe it did
all right well then i will just tell you
about the proximal ord you could plug
proximal origins
into
uh a search engine not google
um but in any case the proximal origins
paper is kristin anderson's paper it's
co-authored with a number of other
people in which he after having
privately said to anthony fauci hey the
genome of this
virus is
inconsistent with evolutionary theory in
the proximal origins paper which you
don't really have entirely here you've
got a reference to it um
click the doi
yep there it is
okay
um
so
let us
to the editor and then we've got a bunch
of stuff here about the chronoval here
at the end of the second paragraph it
says our analysis clearly show that sars
cov2 is not a laboratory construct or a
purposefully manipulated virus now this
is christian anderson lying okay and let
me tell you why i say lying so we've
talked about this paper before but if
you would scroll back up zach i'd just
like to see when
when this is dated so this is dated
just about exactly two years ago that
email interchange that we saw
was from january 31st and february 1st
um usually of course it would take a lot
longer than six weeks even to get
published but yes yes this is pandemic
whatever so
but we have
less than six weeks or you know just
about six weeks between um what is now a
publicly available email saying
inconsistent with uh basically a natural
origin according to
uh what we know about evolution and uh a
a coming out uh
coming out guns blazing saying this is
this is natural it's inconsistent with a
laboratory construct or purposely
manipulated virus now
people can learn a lot of things well
data can show up anderson has been asked
to explain his reversal and he has not
compellingly done so but even
i leave open the possibility that his
perspective could have evolved what i
don't leave open the possibility of is
that he could have written this paper
and not understood the way in which it
was misleading okay
so what the paper argues as we have
discussed once or twice before on
darkhorse
is that this virus has to have come from
nature because we
scientists don't know enough to have
basically written the edits that make it
so effective at invading human cells his
point is look we're just not that good
right
now the reason that that is not just an
error but is clearly a lie
is that we have another mechanism for
improving something like a virus right
we use evolution to solve problems that
we don't know enough to solve directly
right we use serial passaging to get
evolution to favor variants that can
infect things we wouldn't know how to
describe uh the solution to and so
basically the point is what isn't in
that paper
is the proximal origins paper is
any analysis that says this
didn't come from a lab with serial
passaging used as the mechanism to
generate well here we have actually the
last sentence of the paper you can show
my screen if you want zac because i just
pulled up the paper on my
on my computer and a pdf form
irrespective final sentence of the
anderson at all 2020 uh march 17th
2020
uh paper on proximal origins of serious
covey 2 quote irrespective of the exact
mechanisms by which sars kovi 2
originated via natural selection
the ongoing surveillance of pneumonia in
humans and other animals is clearly of
utmost importance
via natural selection
is
is effectively doing very very heavy
lifting now and it there and it always
does of course but
what will not be obvious to most readers
of this paper and what i don't think
would have been obvious to me five years
ago
is that he can mean
their entire zoonotic origin or he can
mean natural selection through serial
passaging in a lab no i think that i
think he
has to mean natural selection in the
wild that artificial selection
uh
i don't i i think he's i think it's
covered i
i don't think it's covered but in any
case
um he clearly lies in this paper
uh by saying that this has to have had a
natural origin by virtue of the fact
that we don't know enough to have
written it okay
that clearly elides what
he and others in this field absolutely
knew which is that they had other
mechanisms at their disposal and what
christian anderson himself clearly knew
in his email exchange with fouchy where
he
he says that the genome is inconsistent
with expectation from evolutionary
theory so to find him now as co-author
on these late emerging reversals right
two of these three late emerging
reversal papers right how how were the
late so now you're talking about the
papers that were cited in the future
how are they reversals of his position
they are reversals of the acceptance
that lab leak was so the mainstream
accepted that lab leak was a viable
explanation many of us had recognized
that it was the explanation to which all
of the evidence which pointed in any
direction actually pointed but not
reversals for him no no he is returning
to his original position my point is the
narrative
sorry i just i don't i don't see how
this is an inconsistency on his part
this feels like it's very consistent
it's not okay the inconsistency is the
world moved on and it stopped fighting
us on lab leak because it kept losing i
mean kristen anderson literally uh
left twitter he he was a laughingstock
right for having written that proximal
origins paper he disappeared for months
from twitter and the point is the world
moves on to ukraine and it's like let's
go back and get that lab leak thing
can't can't be lab leaked because it
vindicates too many too many voices that
we don't want uh
vindicated right well and i mean i think
maybe
maybe more important to many people
than vindicating voices that were right
uh is that if if lab leak if the last
two years um can be blamed on yes
extraordinarily bad
policy that may have been intentionally
bad um but more ultimately than that
uh
this kind of research
which indeed
uh at least within the u.s obama put a
hiatus on and uh and then it just got
shunted over to china by fountain
by you know with you know under the
direction of fauci uh then
really the whole world
should be expected to say at the very
least
no more of this
no more of this
and you know that is part there are all
sorts of reasons that we need that it's
actually totally relevant from a public
health perspective from a virology
perspective from both individual and
population level responses to this
perspective
whether or not this was a naturally
occurring zoonotic virus
versus something that was created sort
of chimera-like in a lab
but it also has specific ramifications
for whether or not this kind of
research should be allowed to continue
at all well it's even stronger than
you're stating it because
really there are two interpretations and
they're polar opposites right
two interpretations of what uh of the
pandemic
if the pandemic emerged from the wuhan
institute right and then if you take
my analysis for example from my unheard
article where i said actually this was a
jump that was unlikely to happen without
human help right
then the point is you must not do this
research because this research is the
most likely source of such a pandemic
and maybe by orders of magnitude right
if on the other hand this emerged from
nature
then they get to make the argument that
they made that
made this happen in the first place
which is
we have no choice but to do this
research in fact with respect to sars
cov2
we hadn't put our foot on the gas hard
enough we weren't ahead enough to do
anything useful with sars kobe 2. and
that's because we hadn't done enough of
this research right and so the point is
those
it's one or the other of these worlds
and it
for those of us who believe that what
we've got
is a laboratory origin and a large
unlikely to be jumped gap between nature
and humans the point is oh boy
somehow we have to
not not only not do this research we
have to not allow this research because
a pandemic
potentially a much worse one could
emerge from a lab quite easily right so
um
anyway that's that's where we are so in
in effect they are resurrecting the
structures oh i wanted to connect one
more
thing here which is
we talked a week or two ago
about the
fact that the
quote-unquote peer-review system that we
have the system of
grant-getting and therefore
back-scratching reciprocal back
scratching that exists in the
publication apparatus and then the grant
getting apparatus
turns scientists it trains them to be
salesmen
and the basic point is what you're
getting as you point out is a sales
pitch for future gain of function
research right
and it's happening
basically at the moment when the world
you know like we all understood that it
was not okay to laugh at the lab leak
hypothesis
right and then ukraine happened and then
papers emerge and people may get the
vague sense that yes for a while we
thought it might have been a lab leak
but then it turned out that it wasn't
there was wasn't there that scientific
work you know
uh that that actually did show that it
was the
the market and of course that work
doesn't exist and you know i don't know
why they didn't keep christian
anderson's name off these papers it's
too obvious
but you know he's there the guy who
reversed himself you know didn't say in
his proximal origins paper what he had
said to anthony fauci right is on these
things and
final point
this isn't just lab leak right who is
christian anderson's boss at the scripps
institute
i don't know it's eric topel
eric i know yes you do know but uh eric
topple has made the rounds uh on early
treatment and vaccine safety and
effectiveness he's been a great champion
of these vaccines right and he went very
exactly a champion of early treatment
however no quite the opposite and he
went very directly after us on sam
harris's podcast i believe i can't
remember the exact quote but i think he
called me a villain of some kind
um but in in any case the point is look
you're a piss-poor villain man
yeah i'm not great at it no um but you
know you just can't manage to stay on
the side of darkness
yeah try as you might and you don't even
try
all right i'm gonna think about that
later there were a couple of reversals
in there but um
but anyway the point the point is right
you've got
some powerful structure i don't know
what job it's doing
but i can see the symptoms the symptoms
involve creating an artificial fringe
where there isn't one uh
involves uh making sure not to vindicate
um
people who were right early as they
embarrassed the mainstream which is too
corrupt to get things right at least
publicly yeah right
it's the same game again and again and
uh
i'm sorry
nothing to do with what you're talking
about for those watching it's just the
dog just knocked over a piece of art
shook herself off wandered off i'm
beginning to think she's in on it
she also makes a very poor villain
however yeah
the worst being a labrador and all yes
there's just there's just no pinning
anything to her
yeah oh
so i guess there is one last piece as
i'm connecting things together you're
gonna be sorry you asked me to do that
um
because you think you said you wanted to
well i did at the end but i'm just at
the beginning which is making it worse
we're closing in on the end at this
point all right um maybe exactly the new
york times article
which what's the subject the new york
times article is on the closely related
subject of hunter biden's laptop
you don't have it
okay so let me just tell you that the
new york times this week acknowledged
that hunter biden's laptop laptop is
indeed the genuine article right
signaling that it is now fine for people
to discuss and polite company the
awkward situation of hunter biden being
a
i don't know a crazed maniac
point of order yep um
i don't know two three episodes ago you
brought to everyone's attention
uh the new
formal
definitions and descriptions of misdis
and mail information yep um that were
published in goshen
the department of homeland security
obviously
and what i didn't see in the
descriptions of miss dis and mail
information which are keeping us very
safe oh so safe um was a description of
at what point um having having had a
piece of information or indeed a person
declared to be a purveyor of misdis or
male information
when
reversals happen yes as apparently has
happened has happened here and i know i
have i have been
avidly paying no attention to the story
um but
what's the what's the protocol like what
is the process you're missing for
becoming
unmiss undis or unmal informed or to no
longer you know to have said something
it's not like that oh you you have
missed the glory of mal information
because here's the thing let's say you
take the laptop story we'll need a
reminder so mal information is it's true
but we don't like it right now it's true
but it causes you to mistrust the
government
okay
okay right
okay so so check me out here do you
remember back during the
uh election
uh of 2020 which one yeah yeah the
recent presidential elections remember
that fella from the apprentice was
running against that fella who's
lost his marbles
indeed right okay some of us at the time
you will remember were quite alarmed
about the hunter biden
laptop and the reason we were alarmed
was that there were some remarkable
things there a it suggested a kind of
out of controlness right there in the
first family but that's obviously not
the presidential candidate but b much
more importantly it suggested
that hunter was selling his father's
influence right he was peddling
influence where was he peddling
influence ukraine right and so the point
is wow this is really dangerous you
remember what we were guilty of at the
time
it was misinformation because the whole
idea that this was really hunter biden's
laptop and that those things were true
that was russian disinformation okay now
the new york times acknowledges it was
not right
people saying this yes were
were engaged in misinformation because
they had fallen prey to russian
disinformation right the russians had
but now it turns out it's mal
information because it is true but it's
still bad for the government now you're
getting it
okay so the point is this is this is
great we did it
when this was misinformation according
to the dhs's modern taxonomy of
terrorism which surely they were they
had a private version of back then when
this was misinformation because the
russians had planted this laptop with
false stuff on it so that we would
believe it right yes when it was
misinformation it was terrorism okay
now that it turns out according to the
new york times the laptop is genuine it
is mal information and therefore
terrorism still terrorism right exactly
now why is the new york times not guilty
so the addition of mal information to
the uh to the taxonomy yep
allows for there to be no
mechanism by which you s you have to
slide between categories because you can
keep track if you want to but regardless
you're definitely guilty of terrorism i
told you this was gonna happen yeah
you're putting it all together the fact
is you can't be resurrected for having
had the hunter biden laptop story
correct back during the election still a
terrorist right exactly you will not be
vindicated right because we don't
vindicate terrorists because they're bad
people yeah right okay so otherwise they
wouldn't be terrorists
yeah exactly or something right or
something so anyway the the real mystery
is why the new york times is not going
to be uh
i don't know closed down over its
airing of this um
well on our
laptop story which no this i mean
because and you know i don't i don't
have the taxonomy i don't have access to
the inside thinking of the dhs of course
i'm not up to their level um but because
the new york times was working in the
interests of the government back when it
turns out to have been spreading
misinformation
itself
[Music]
that was the opposite of mal information
which gave it a pass
it it was like like you go right to go
you pass go you collect your 200
and that's going to protect you
when engaging in anti-mal information
you have a get out of misinformation
free card
i believe you have just
grabbed the brass ring because what you
have effectively done is you have said
the only
cure
for mal information
is anti-mal information
right this is a kendeism but extend it
into a new realm
and i think the new york times is
inherently anti-mal information and
inherently candiest
that they are
um this has gotten silly this has guns
well you know the dhs is a silly
organization
a little bit too silly um
what better moment to talk about uh
trans athletes i i knew we were we were
gonna get there yeah can we can we can
we wrap it into that brass ring moment
though yeah well you like you you said
you saw a connection
so far we've done great on the
connecting stuff yeah okay well i um
leah thomas
uh
born and went through puberty and indeed
competed in swimming competitions
um
asmail
just won the just won
one or more uh ncaa swimming
championships in the women's divisions
uh
the new york times
for again i chose the wrong week to
switch to brave and to oh here it is
here it's gonna be
um
here we have
uh
the new york times you can show my
screen here
um
leah thomas wins an ncaa swimming title
there
leah is
um
before i say anything more about this i
i would like to know
what the hell the university of
pennsylvania
is thinking
and um what this person's parents think
about this
remarkable transformation
from loser to winner is really what the
transformation is because there hasn't
been that much transformation of
the underlying maleness of of this
person
what we find in this
in this article
is
thomas's triumph in atlanta indeed her
very presence at the swimming
championships as a contender came amid a
far larger storm particularly in state
houses and right-wing media
about sports participation by
transgender girls and women
it is incredible it is utterly
incredible that recognition of a
depending upon how you count 500 million
to 2 billion with a b
year old reality
can be dismissed
by the new york times
as the purview of
right-wing media
why why would the new york times the
grey lady is that what it's called
yeah yeah yeah why would the new york
times which once prided itself on being
the source of news for americans at
least the source of print news for
americans
pride itself on abandoning all reason
and i mean this
the
the binary nature of sex in our lineage
which is at least 500 million years old
is recognizable by everyone
it is recognizable even
if you're
a cat
who
doesn't have all of his parts anymore
he's still a boy yeah he's still a boy
and
this
oh i'm sorry i didn't realize i was
still on but you can keep me on here
zach let me just read one more one more
um excerpt from this new york times
article
thomas
again
born went through puberty uh competed as
male
thomas and her rise though forced the
typically plotting ncaa to grapple more
quickly with a subject that scientists
are still examining
and its consequences for sports
competitions
comprehensive research in athletes is
still lacking but early studies suggest
suppressing testosterone in transgender
women decreases muscle mass and
hemoglobin levels reducing how much
oxygen can be carried through the
bloodstream
most of the changes occur within the
first year of hormone suppression but
transgender women may still have more
muscle mass than their cisgender peers
even after three years
as some insist that no amount of
testosterone suppression can undo the
physiolog physiological changes linked
to male puberty like taller height and
larger hands and feet others dispute
that transgender women have a built-in
advantage and have argued that inclusion
should outweigh competition
i have a few things to say here yeah
inclusion should outweigh competition
this is sport
if you want to go
swim with your buddies
and there's some question about whether
or not you want someone to participate
you can talk about whether or not in
this case inclusion should win the day
but in sports it's about competition
it's not about hey i want to compete
because guess why i know i will win
because i'm going to be cheating by
competing in that division
so here are just
a few there's there's abundant
abundant evidence here but um i happen
to have
you can you can show my screen here i
happen to have written a
article back in 2019
over three years ago for my patreon um
that i have opened up it's publicly
available should trans women compete
against women in professional sports
no
and i i joke here that this is a short
article i did go on though
uh to uh to to make a number of
arguments and i recommend i recommend
that you follow them but one of the
things i do is also
point to this
uh
this table which it turns out here let
me see if i can find it
is
in
okay zach just give me my screen back
for a second while i find
yeah uh the table in question
oh
boy
nothing is working that's snakes that's
totally different isn't it
um
okay well i don't unfortunately got
closed when when my computer crashed
earlier so i'm going to go back in here
and just show you this here i will i
will link to the actual actual paper
this is
from sex you can show my screen here sex
differences that suggest male design for
combat in humans this is from if memory
serves a uh
sorry 2012 paper called the importance
of physical strength to human males
and just some of the some of the ways uh
that males and females are different is
that males have greater upper body
strength taller bodies heavier bodies
higher basal metabolic rates faster
reaction times thicker bones in the jaw
faster mental rotation and spatial
visualization that's the bit where
you get shown something you're asked
what would happen what would it look
like if you rotate 90 degrees to the
left something like that
more accurate throwing more accurate
blocking of thrown objects more interest
in the practice of compact skills combat
skills stronger bones greater bone
density specifically in the arms on and
on and on and on
and more recently and here um you can
show yeah you're still on my screen good
um no
um
here we have this paper
published in sports medicine in i think
it went online first in 2020 and it was
officially published in 2021
a review by emma hilton and tommy
lundberg called transgender women in the
female category of sport perspectives on
testosterone suppression and performance
advantage
a very compelling
review of all of the evidence which
finds to
no one's surprise if they are thinking
carefully about this
that taking a single metric for whether
or not you are male or female which is
to say circulating levels of
testosterone at the moment
and deciding that that's the thing that
you're going to count and and use to
decide whether or not you're male or
female and used to decide whether or not
you have any advantage is woefully
inaccurate i mean in inadequate and um
frankly if you've if you were born male
and if you went through puberty male 1
and
um and you have recently been on
cross-sex hormones but retain
basically every other
other manifestation of maleness
competing against women is cheating
that's just true
all right i've got a number of things i
want to add yeah
one i always
we are facing
a an epidemic of sophistry across
every domain it's a true epidemic i mean
it really is right and the point is i
hear you making points that shouldn't
require they don't need to be made
frankly i mean look you can win this
argument in one move if you're held to a
reasonable standard right
does anything that we do
in the
medical practice of transitioning
males to trans femaleness
change the height of the individuals
who have been transitioned
it doesn't
right or the skeletal structure maybe
maybe bone density my point is even just
one parameter that the fact is you know
were you a tall guy yes
are you going to be a
tall woman
we don't know
yes we do in fact you're gonna be an
exceptionally tall woman because you
were a tall guy and you're not gonna get
shorter i mean maybe maybe you get a
little shorter but you don't get a lot
shorter so anyway my point is this is
obvious right this is this is really an
emperor has no closed moment
is it fair for
somebody to go through puberty as male
declare themselves female have
procedures whatever they are and then
join women's sports no
simply no because one thing we can say
is this doesn't fully reverse
the transitions that male puberty
uh
causes the body to go through right it's
a simple
simple conclusion pre-puberty boys and
girls have much more similar both
interests and skill sets right
now
um second thing is
oh the new york times is interested in
the question about how we you know
balance the
desire to be inclusive in sport
uh with the uncertainty of the evidence
as scientists mull over this question
right follow the science new york times
find better scientists any scientist
who's confused by this isn't really good
at their job go look at the hilton and
lundberg paper and you know one one
thing so i have actually hilton emma
hilton and colin wright and i have
written a couple pieces together so i i
know her and she's terrific um but one
of the things that we had talked about
sort of behind the scenes was people
would ask us
like well you know what what's you know
what are the primary what's the primary
literature what's the scientific
literature on the idea that men and
women are different right and like it's
it's actually too obvious ever to have
been written down that way yes
what is the scientific evidence that
plants are inferior at warfare
well if you can't produce a piece of
primary literature it must not be true
and furthermore i'm really hoping that
you have a randomized control trial for
that you're better you better have a
randomized controlled trial because
otherwise the you know the trees that
are best at warfare
i don't know something but okay so
you know the new york times is is is
wrestling it is grappling with the
question of inclusion versus scientific
certitude oh boy are they wrestling
which is
total sophistry because i would
point out that the very nature of
women's sports
uh makes uh clear that inclusion is not
the goal
right why are men not ordinarily
included in women's sports right right
because there is a value in having
sports in which women can actually
compete on a level playing field with
other women and not face the biological
disadvantage
that sexual dimorphism has exposed them
to what about the woman who came in
fourth in the race that leah thomas won
right
why isn't she included on the podium
where she belongs exactly
now
uh i'm also you asked the question about
what leah thomas's parents think yeah i
did you know in general i don't i don't
love that sort of approach but in this
case i really do i really do wonder
actually legitimately well i i
found myself in a different place on the
start okay which was wondering about
leah thomas
and here's the point um let me just be
clear about this we have said many times
when we have discussed transness on this
uh on this channel that
we do not regard
transness as inherently a malfunction
right there there's too much transness
in too many populations and there are
long-standing traditions about how it is
addressed now that is not to say
anything about medical transition or
anything like that
however or the rate at which it is
prevalent now right in the west right
which could be the result of all kinds
of
disruptive
influences but it is not inherently
malfunction okay
but here's the point
what does it say about a person
that they go through
life
mail they go through puberty mail
right they go through competitions mail
they go through competitions mail they
then let's say that they
genuinely feel they're born in the wrong
body fine
do they not look at their victory in a
competition like this and feel
embarrassment right the point is look
okay
so you're trans
why are you picking a realm
where
you have an advantage from your having
transitioned rather than having been
born in the other body why wouldn't you
pick a realm where you're not cheating
and everybody knows that you're not
cheating right so i guess the question
is what is the state of mind of somebody
who could actually go home with a medal
from an event and feel good about it
right i don't understand the feeling
good about it and i it's not that i you
know i want people who
experience transness whatever it is
to find their true selves and to feel
good about it right but
this this ought to make anyone feel good
right this is that's right this is
cheating and you know getting a medal
through cheating you shouldn't look at
the metal and feel good
right now you you should not
and um
the fact that
a good part of the world can see
what's wrong here
is is is one thing
and then that there's another part of
the world that is somehow willfully
blinding itself
because it's been told that in order to
be a good person that's what you do
in order to be a good person
you uh move the syringes out of your
twitter bio and move in the ukrainian
flag in order to be a good person
you talk about how amazing it is that
leah thomas beat out a bunch of women in
swimming
even though it's utterly obvious that
this person would do so there's no
sportsmanship there there's
you know this person was a competent
enough swimmer to be doing middlingly
well as a male swimmer until basically
yesterday
of course leah thomas is going to win
against women
and if it were true
that it is not true but if it were true
that there was some mechanism for
reversing
all of the advantages that come through
uh male physiology and male puberty
then there would be a
well-defined literature that would
describe the pattern so that we would
know how many years had to pass with
what kinds of therapies before the
advantage had been neutralized and you
could join women's sports and the reason
that there is no well-defined literature
and the reason that the new york times
finds itself grappling with the question
of scientists who can't figure this one
out is because this is political it is
not scientific right
the inability to get to the answer is
the point and um you know and i guess
how many different realms do we need to
see
nonsense masquerading as science before
we say oh my god what has taken over our
scientific system and what kind of
danger is implied by that breakage yeah
and i guess i i finished that patreon
article that i that i showed
um by saying
also
uh i will call
i will call people trans women
uh i have
avoided doing that in this particular
case because this looks
this looks like transitional soft
history at some level
um
but what i won't do
is call women cis women
or men cis men although
it's not really that surprising that
that's not where this fight is taking
place
and
i will also
not say nor do i
believe that
given again the 500 million to two
billion years of evolution
that is that is part of our lineage
that the statement trans women are women
is true
women are women
trans women is a new category
and
it does not have a 500 million to two
billion year history at all it is a new
category
and
we can be
kind and compassionate
and um
and respectful
without throwing out reality
and being unkind uncompassionate and
disrespectful to all of the women who
are being hurt by this the children who
are being harmed
uh the you know it goes on and on and on
and society and i just are reckoning
with reality that takes a hit every time
we are told to utter one of these
completely wrong-headed and insane
sentences like trans women are women
yeah now
i think
i would say my policy is i will treat
trans women as women or trans men as men
for every purpose where that does not
harm somebody else and the basic point
is at the point you get to things like
prisons or
sports uh then
we have to we have to look at the
reality now i would point out i went to
leah thomas's wikipedia page
and um it
it it has this shocking feature which i
i would recommend people go to it and
read it it's not the first time i've
seen it where the thing is written in
such a way so as to tread
carefully around the
modern convention of not quote-unquote
misgendering right and so the point is
it is cleverly written even from before
it's like it's like the
the sexical equivalent of dead naming
it's like dead sexy right exact it's
dead sexing and um so what they do is in
places where it would be you know
obviously this person has a history as a
boy and then as a man and competed as a
boy and a man right and so instead of
saying you know and didn't win races he
competed blah blah blah then
transitioned now she competes right that
would be a
literal if we accept that she is a she
that is a literal description instead
what they do is where they would say he
they say thomas right the last name
um
right so as not to be so is to be gender
neutral and then at the point that the
person has transitioned they say she
and
uh even worse than this in the case
of um chelsea manning
right
i've seen the new york times rolling
stone magazine and i believe wikipedia
all engaged the fiction that chelsea
manning delivered documents
to julian assange
which did not happen that is
historically false right so here's the
question if this is all so clear because
because
i can't even remember his name at the
time bradley manning did that
and later transitioned in prison maybe
even right uh came out in in prison yeah
yeah
i mean it is
it's like it's like the opposite of
reality and it does it does once again
feel very post-modernist it's what i
currently believe
is not only reality but it has always
been reality
and the fact that i didn't always
believe it
doesn't change anything which also
leaves me open to changing my mind
tomorrow at which point that has always
been reality and if you believe me today
and then don't update your understanding
of my belief of reality tomorrow in
keeping with my understanding then
you've slighted me it's a
microaggression for god's sake it might
be a mega aggression who knows it's
actually it's a kind of weird immunity
from hypocrisy or for being you know
convicted of hypocrisy right to change
your mind you should acknowledge that
you've changed your mind to be able to
go backwards and say oh i always
i always believe that i always was that
is nonsense and this actually comes to
the point for me which is the solution
to this problem it
wikipedia
should absolutely be steadfast in being
able to write i mean wikipedia is a
dumpster fire at the moment yes but
wikipedia of old that aspired to a
neutral perspective
should simply write stories that track
the person's
presentation their gender at the moment
that incidents happen bradley manning
gave documents to julian assange uh in
prison bradley manning
came out and said he was chelsea manning
and has been treated as chelsea manning
ever since right that should be what's
written
and the idea that we can't write that
because we're treading lightly around
sensitivities says that we are not
dealing with objectivity and i think the
solution to this
involves
rational trans people confronting this
right and actually we saw this a bit
caitlyn jenner
came out uh
against the competition of women and uh
of trans women in women's sports and the
basic point is look i'm defending women
it's the right thing to do um and you
know uh uh why am i forgetting uh a buck
angel
grandpa has also been very good on this
issue and so look
there are a number there are a number of
people most not quite as
as public as them but i i know some
trans people too who are actively like
going to for instance um you know state
um
state hearings
trans people saying
trans people should not be competing
um as the sex that they were not born to
right in
in sport trans women
and um and it's it's powerful because
these are people who actually do have
the yes lived experience of
of the
of the pain and horror of the gender
dysmorphia
that actually causes some very tiny
number of people
to to transition and the people who are
abusing
the ability to transition and for
example compete against uh you know
women
those people are robbing trans people
who are just trying to live a life with
extra complexities exactly right and so
i i really do hope that there is a an
emergence of uh
you know a wise consensus amongst trans
people who spot how crazy this is indeed
um we
have gone way longer than i thought we
should but i have one last thing if i
may um boy i actually have five last
things but let's let's do this this one
actually
two very quickly
um because we take on uh woke and
covered woke uh all the time and many
confuse uh woke with being on the left
because that is the claim
i found a really stupid anti-feminist
right-wing take on twitter this week
that i thought i'd share because you
know why not why not point out the
stupid wherever it shows up
uh so here it is
uh zach just briefly if a woman
hyphenates or doesn't take her husband's
last name when she gets married she
doesn't respect him
so you can take that down now so i can
have my have my notes back i really hope
that's not true
right um
th this there's there's a lot of places
that i could go here but this feels just
as shallow and daft a point as the idea
that if white women have a food cart in
which they make burritos that they
learned how to make when they were in
mexico they're engaging in cultural
appropriation need to be shut down and
yes that did happen in portland a few
years ago and yes they did have to shut
down their business and they're done
right and um and boy when i went looking
into that story i'm like well you know
they admitted to looking at what the
mexican women were doing at some points
when the when the women weren't totally
uh you know interested in having them
look and so maybe they were actually
thieving it's like okay i'd like to know
more about that how come i'm only
finding that in these stories that have
already concluded that any time
people from a different lineage make
food of one of one lineage and that's
cultural appropriation that's dumb
this is also dumb this is shallow and
daft doesn't recognize the many many
ways
that human beings have lived have have
decided to track lineage
and is it you know is it true that in a
culture
that has been
patrilineal which is just to say that we
tend to track
lineage through the male line
that is easier if everyone follows the
same the same naming conventions yeah
yeah it would be right
however
in an era in which women have are
recognized as having as much capacity
and always of course have but actually
have um just about as much opportunity
if not absolutely as much opportunity if
not in some places more opportunity at
this point
than men to actually find
the way that they want to make a
difference in the world be it you know
creative analytical
exploring
writing healing whatever it is
the idea that one has to change their
name from that of their father to that
of their husband upon getting married
is archaic and is disruptive of a
woman's ability to to make a life in the
world
it has nothing to do
with not respecting the man that she is
marrying
just as
a man taking you know just as
well there's a lot there's a lot of ways
it has nothing to do with disrespecting
the man that she's marrying it is a
recognition of a woman being a complete
member of the partnership with goals
that and and values and interests that
are independent in the world that there
are now three entities there's the man
and there's the woman and there's
there's the couple
and you know in our case
in our case we decided that because of
the culture that we live in it was
important and valuable uh to give our
children your name
and there was i i think we may have
talked about this before but there may i
don't even remember that we talked about
that we certainly talked about our names
a bit
um
and
um you know even considered at some
point maybe combining them but both of
our names are ridiculous enough that
that was you know we're gonna end up
with whining or something and you know
it just didn't make any sense precisely
because the idea is like you've always
been brett weinstein i've always been
how they're hiring and we were gonna
continue to do that now also in
partnership
but our children have never been
anything
and furthermore
there is
evolutionary reason for a patrilineal
naming
convention with regard to children which
is that
in a situation where the children are
the genetic children of the mom
i don't have any uncertainty about
whether or not i'm their mother
and i also don't have any uncertainty
about whether or not you're the father
but the rest of the world might
hey
they shouldn't no not i guess take your
i mean
this is just simply this is the nature
this is simply it and so we are we are
signaling to the world the truth
uh which is that we are a family and
yeah i have the name i was born with but
the four of us are a family and our
children um have your name and that that
therefore raises no questions as it
should not so i i take this
uh
as a
simple example of a canonical problem
right used to be
that a household involved a man
breadwinner went out and did things in
the world to the extent that somebody
was going to start a sawmill or
innovate it was likely to be the guy
the woman was part of a team but the
element of the team
teamwork was largely done on the home
front that's not a fair thing but that's
the way biology set things up
uh the modern world it's not that
old that you know that pattern is
maybe as old as agriculture
um yep i would agree but you know these
naming conventions are
post-agriculture
right there are pre there are naming
conventions that go before that but i
guess my point is in a world where
biology has settled women with domestic
work
um
what you have is a division of labor and
a team and that team has a name and it
made sense in some ways for that name to
be the forward-facing part of the team
name name dad name name public facing
public-facing person was the name of the
team that was public facing right
therefore also the name of the team
inside right and in modern circumstances
largely as a result of birth control
women have
been liberated to participate in the
world in
you know
innovation and
productivity outside the home and that's
a great thing but the point is it
creates a situation in which we do not
have a solution for the naming
convention that we inherited all
solutions are bad right including the
solution of everybody keeps their own
name and then the kids have one person's
name or the other person's name right
hyphenating
i find myself when i write to the kids
schools or the you know teachers who i
don't who don't know me i'm like you
know
heather hang
zach weinstein's mom you know just in
case you were wondering you know like
who am i why you know why is this random
person writing when the kid is a
different name but that's that's a tiny
little cost well yeah i think the point
is
there's a tiny little cost with all
solutions they're all bad literally all
of us hyphenating is a bigger cost i
think right because it's not sustainable
exactly hyphenating hyphenating is worse
choosing one or the other is worse it
negates the nature of children
right um
how you choose one or the other is
fraught and so the point is yeah
nobody's got a solution to this and the
problem with that perspective is that it
basically points to one of the solutions
and
um doesn't recognize what's wrong with
it and what's wrong with it does it
recognize exhaustion in a world where
both men and women are building
reputations in the world the fact that
somebody has to effectively be
nominally trans
that's not the way it sounds but the
idea that you have to transition your
identity at the point that you marry a
it's arbitrary because marriage isn't
what it used to be right
marriage used to be the point at which
you start producing children and some
married people don't produce children
by choice and some people have children
before they marry and so
the whole system has come apart and the
fact that it was also much more widely
understood to be a permanent condition
yeah so you know
i do think that part of what underlies
that you know conservative that wrong
conservative take
is a recognition that increasingly
people get married thinking if it works
it works if it doesn't it doesn't
and um you know really it is supposed to
be permanent and sometimes it can't be
sometimes it doesn't work out um but
there would be an additional cost for
sure there would be additional reasons
to stay in a marriage if you're like and
i have to and i'm now going to go back
to the person that i was then in terms
of my name like there are additional
problems with actually becoming
independent and having a public-facing
persona in the world um if you might be
changing your name all the time yeah i
don't think of it as a permanent
condition i think of it as a chronic
condition do you
i don't know it seemed like something to
say but sure um yeah one way or the
other
okay let's just end um zach would you
show the picture that i sent you which
is the sign that i saw in in portland uh
this week um i was walking around a
neighborhood actually i guess i could
mention um in cellwood and there were
all these actually take it off for a
second i'm sorry um
there are all of these places as we
talked about last week the mask mandates
lifted a week ago today
and
there are still a lot of people walking
around in masks even outside some much
less outside but in a lot of stores and
there are still a lot of signs on a lot
of stories including like coffee shops
and restaurants where you would walk in
with a mask sit down and take it off a
lot of signs that say masks still
required
amazing right
and i have complained uh in this space
before
that you also have a whole lot of signs
about equity and inclusion
exactly from organizations that are then
saying actually no vax no entry
but this is a sign that i saw this week
in amongst other
thank you and amongst other businesses
we do not discriminate it says against
any customer based on sex gender race
creed age vaccinated or unvaccinated all
customers who wish to patronize are
welcome in our establishment
and um
it is it was heartening it was beyond
heartening and it's a it's a terrific
story too i'm actually just not going to
mention it here right now until
um
until i talk to them about whether or
not they would like me to um
but uh
really
really heartening to see
if if if you're going to say the things
that really shouldn't need to be said
you know we welcome both men and women
and people of all genders whatever that
might mean um people of all creeds which
is more or less religion
um and vaccinated or unvaccinated like
if you're gonna say all that first part
and if you're actually gonna mean it and
if you think that it needs to be said
which i i would have hoped by now in the
history of
humans we wouldn't need to be saying
that now but if you think it needs to be
said then yes then yes also to uh
decisions about um medical history um
that really have no right
no reason for other people to know much
less
much less ask ask for and care about um
especially given the nature of these
particular decisions
yeah that is heartening especially in
light of the
rate of mass voluntary massness in in
portland at the moment yeah anyway maybe
that will
change over time yeah indeed all right
um we are going to take a break we are
going to probably curtail the q a a fair
bit because
we went on longer than we were going to
um
you can ask your questions at
www.darkhorsemissions.com
you can
you can do all sorts of good stuff you
can
you can read our book you can find us on
patreon
where you have access to the discord
server we start off every q a with a
question from the discord server the
darkhorse discord server which you get
access to in either of our patreons
and
i would remind you two
be good to the ones you love eat good
food
and get outside
be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you